my name is Katie Hillary I am a junior
classics and history major from Los
Angeles California and tonight I have
the privilege of introducing to you
tonight's speaker dr. Alvin silver Alan
silver received his PhD in theatre arts
and motion pictures from the University
of California Los Angeles dr. silver is
a member of the Writers Guild of America
West and the Directors Guild of America
he produced his produced screenplays
include kiss daddy goodbye in an
adaptation of Dostoevsky White Knights
which he also directed his credits as a
producer include crashing prime suspect
night visitor and torch he has written
essays for The Criterion DVD releases of
samurai spy and the Seven Samurai he has
also provided audio or video
commentaries for numerous movies
including war films such as murder my
sweet
thieves highway panic in the streets
the dark corner kiss of death the street
with no name and where danger lives
he is a author of the samurai film and
the American neo-noir
and co-editor of film noir an
encyclopedic reference to the American
style as well as film noir light and
shadow safe to say that dr. silver is
very haunted and we are welcoming up
here him to the stage tonight to speak
with us please join us in welcoming dr.
Alan silver thank you and good evening I
hope those of you who are here had the
opportunity to see the film earlier
tonight or know about it I have a lot to
cover so I'm gonna get right to it so I
have to ask myself where to begin with
the back story as complex as Double
Indemnity
there are some underlying factors that
affected this movie and what I'm going
to do before I tackle Double Indemnity
is film noir is introduced a few pieces
of significant context let's start with
number one true crime
in 1925 a disaffected 30 year old
housewife named Ruth Snyder was
unhappily ensconced in Queens Village
Long Island with her stuffy 42 year old
husband Albert an art director for motor
boating magazine and her young daughter
a grade schooler named Warren not Lola
that June on one of her many shopping
outings to Manhattan a tall blond haired
Ruth was introduced to a traveling
lingerie salesman named Henry Judd gray
she didn't care
that he wore thick horn rimmed glasses
or was shorter than her that he had a
wife and child living on the Jersey
Shore maybe it was his cleft chin maybe
she was just that bored but they quickly
fell in each others arms and began a
torrid love affair soon Ruth was no
longer content with the occasional
Rhonda booze and speakeasies such as
these that serve throats during
Prohibition era cocktails and they would
be followed by dalliance as at the
Waldorf Astoria they were there so
frequently that the couple kept a
checked bag with the clerk they had an
unofficial sort of domesticity and that
was evidenced by the contents of the bag
that the police ultimately opened his in
her PJ's toothbrushes a deck of playing
cards a copy of the novel by Anita Luce
that was called Gentlemen Prefer Blondes
sorry I skipped ahead too fast so Ruth
preferred more she nursed her resentment
about Albert who made a good living but
he wasn't wealthy who still doted on a
dead girlfriend from 10 years passed and
she'd been thinking for a while about
removing the punctilious editor from her
life she may even have tried it once
before would poison but all it did was
give the unsuspecting Albert a
stomachache now she wanted him gone and
divorce was still not hurt Rosen method
unlike Walter and Phyllis momsie and bud
as the real-life lovers called him
selves we're not careful planners in
November of 1925 Ruth sat in her parlor
with Leroy Ashfield and a
in true Prudential to discuss life
insurance on her dear Albert Ashfield
later recounted what Ruth had said she
told me that her husband would be home
on a certain night later in the week
and she requested that I call and see
him in reference to insurance in the
event he was not interested she said at
least get his signature and that she'd
be able to persuade him later does that
sound familiar well that's not a line
from the screen player or the novel that
it was taken from that is the statement
from a trial transcript
when Ashfield testified in the murder
trial and that trial was the sensation
of 1927 it was not merely that was in
all the papers and here is angry denial
that you ever had an affair anyone else
it was a sensation worldwide even the
New York Times and I couldn't find any
of their headlines had it on their front
page for weeks and in the tabloids they
were known as ruthless Ruth or the
granite lady or the tiger woman and poor
oops John I give Judd more impact than
he should have
so Ruth was still elegant in jail what
is not clear from Leroy's testimony is
if Ruth served him any iced tea but she
ended up with a double indemnity policy
that would pay out ninety thousand
dollars that's it's a hair under 1.2
million dollars in today's money from
nonchalantly acquiring a small fortune
and life insurance coverage the lovers
just got sloppier their ultimate Lee
ninety-one years ago tomorrow on March
20th of 1927 Judd brought a sash wait
some picture wire to the Snider house in
Queens and after making use of those
drawers were open content strewn
everywhere and this next is a little
grisly but it's hard to see
Albert's top brake revolver was
displayed on the bed as if it had failed
this Ward of burglary and left behind
was inside the wire used to tighten
around Albert's neck a metal pen with
initials JG for Judd gray less than an
hour after being summoned to the house
the police had handcuffs on Ruth and
we're looking to slap another pair on
gray so writing for the Hearst syndicate
just four weeks after the killing Damon
Runyon described the start of the trial
this way and this is from the Chicago
Tribune
it's a chronology of the crime what
Runyan said was rich Snyder and Judd
gray are on trial for what might be
called the dumbbell murder now I just
want to go back he's not referring to
the sash wait no no he was referring to
the fact that their plan was so dumb and
I quote under circumstances that for
sheer stupidity and brutality have never
been equaled in the history of crime
okay for Hawking the insurance policy
Leroy Ashfield was fired by Prudential
what happened to bud and momsie wasn't
so nice as you'll see from this headline
they were found guilty they were sent to
sing sing and in early 1928 just ten
months after the botched crime they took
turns sitting in the electric chair that
is the actual moment of rich nighters
electrocution the Daily News snuck in a
guy from Chicago with a camera strapped
to his leg so sitting amongst Runyan and
other well-known crime reporters in that
courtroom was a 35 year old journalist
who'd recently moved from the Baltimore
Sun to the New York Herald James Cain he
was cheating on a wife he left behind in
Maryland that doesn't mean he identified
with Judd gray but he knew a good store
when he saw it what he probably also saw
was this headline which was reproduced
around the world Kane was already
writing plays and short stories for the
american mercury and pretty soon he had
an agent and a hollywood deal as a staff
screenwriter paramount were reputedly
one of the first things he did was
tinkering dialogue for a sound remake of
DeMille 10 commandments probably none of
that dialogue got into the ultimate
remake like so many who preferred prose
fiction Kane and this is what he looked
like at the time had little use for
Hollywood except that it paid well I
wanted the picture money Kane said and I
worked like a dog to get it I parked my
pride my aesthetic convictions my mind
outside on the street and did everything
to be a success in this highly paid
trade still even a whorehouse well the
girl has to like her work a little bit
and I could not like pictures so Kane
kept writing on its own material and his
first novel was partially inspired by
Snyder gray and that it's adulterous
lovers turned on each other this was
published in 1934 his fictional killers
get away with the crime and came mused
about that and then what they would find
that the earth is not big enough for two
persons who share such a dreadful secret
and eventually they would turn on each
other
Kane went all in on this concept the
next year and I should say that MGM did
purchase postman in 1934 but because MGM
got hung up the explanation is here it
didn't get made for a long time and by
the time Cades Adrian got the draft of
his novella Double Indemnity
out to the Hollywood studios for reasons
I'm going to explain shortly they all
passed so that first appeared in Liberty
magazine
with special significance as regards
Double Indemnity both novel and film is
the motion picture code some of you are
familiar with the MPAA perhaps the
present Motion Picture Association of
American part of what it does is
administer the rating systems each
member has to get a seal of approval to
distribute their movies but back then
the guidelines weren't official they
were set forth in what was known as the
code or the Hays Code after this
gentleman and what the Hays Code did
after he was hired in 1927 was supposed
to take some of the pressure off the
studio's darting before World War one in
Chicago in 1907 many cities had local
censorship boards and they weren't
authorized to restrict exhibition or
entirely ban movies in 1911 Pennsylvania
formed a state board by 1922 there were
five more states including New York that
had boards and a hundred cities and they
were applying wildly different criteria
to feature films now movies like this
Hedy Lamarr's Czechoslovakian
Czechoslovakia and debut and ecstasy
could never cut the mustard with any of
these boards but what the industry was
interested in was getting something
formalized that meant if they adhered
they wouldn't have a problem with any of
these boards that's why they oh I will
Hays there is again as part of the
promise to keep movies if not completely
wholesome at least acceptable for family
viewing what we would call today no
worse than the PG what that gentleman
did in 1927 was put together a list of
suggestion for his producer members some
were things that couldn't be depicted at
all like childbirth ridiculing the
clergy miscegenation forbidden outright
were profanity and nudity including miss
Lamar's then there was a list of gray
areas subjects that could be dramatized
with considerable circumspection
I'm especially to use the title of a
current hit show how to get away with
murder drug use enhanced interrogation
techniques even a very institution of
marriage so I'm sure you folks know
selling movies has always been a
business and all these suggestions were
fine in principle but the studios and
the independent distributors that there
were back then they continued to push
the envelope now I'm not talking about
outliers like reefer madness or
countless stag reels made not by members
of the MPAA but fly-by-night production
companies that breezed in and out of
town made a few bucks before the local
boards could catch up to them now I mean
mainstream movies
I mean madam Satan before he became
something of a Bluenose sasol B DeMille
in 1929 and 30 made a godless girl
dynamite and madam Satan which is the
one on the screen as their titles might
suggest he blithely ignored a lot of
will Hayes's suggestions and shortly
after these pictures hit the theaters
nerving thales burg that's him
a little more attractive and will Hays
he was a young head of production at MGM
he had a meeting with a couple of
Catholic activists who had on their own
taken the Hayes list of taboo topics and
made a formal code a month after that
meeting in March 1930 the MPA adopted
the code so here's the thing whether it
was an informal code or a code with a
capital C for the studio executives
tonal line was another matter in 1932
and 33 MGM released redheaded woman
Warner Brothers produced female and
babyface and United Artists distributed
the Greeks had a word for them three
young ladies loose in New York again I
will let the title speak for themselves
ten years before Double Indemnity baby
chronicled the fictional affairs of Lily
powers who sleeps her way to the top and
the tag line on the poster read she had
it and made it pay Lilly was portrayed
by Barbara's
anyway yes that is John Wayne with her
but I don't think Fred MacMurray ever
made any stag reels many believe the
final straw for local censors was not
the loose morals of the fictional young
women but a spate of gangster films
released in the early 1930s
so the best-known of these movies were
Scarface with Paul Muni as Al Capone
that's George Raft as his sidekick
Edward J Robinson long before he became
Barton Keyes as another Italian gangster
and Little Caesar or James Cagney as the
Irish mobster in Public Enemy these
criminal protagonists or some would have
to say heroes they all end up dead but
on the way these characters they break a
lot of laws and they also kill more than
one or two people so a lot of the
censors raised hell so that movies would
not be banned new endings were shot
introductory texts and even film
prologue decrying organized crime added
but the unsavory Astor tastes does these
gangster movies lingered in 1934 the
acts finally fell on the freewheeling
narratives of Hollywood in June the MPAA
established the PCA or production code
administration with offices on each
coast to enforce rules that had not been
strictly followed since being ratified
in 1932 head the PCA they hired Joseph I
bring away from the Catholic Legion of
decency
the original rating organization they
just had three categories a four
acceptable B for bad C for condemned
okay truth B is for morally
objectionable in part but when I was a
kid in parochial school B was for bad
the studio's didn't really mind a B
rating from the Legion of decency but a
C would likely affect their ticket sales
their bottom line
now Breen not only did he want to take
the gun out of a tree Robinson's hand he
didn't really like the clinch that was
going on in front of it these were not
things that the code wanted to see on
screen so dairy producers could still
make any movie they wanted
we're not telling you what to do but
when you needed an MPA a seal of
approval to release the movie you needed
a thumbs-up from Joe Breen that is the
gentleman in the 50s he held that job
for over 20 years
okay those are the prelims let's talk
about film noir let's start with the
term which entered the English language
to the extent that noir is a standalone
adjective I mean you can apply it to
anything from novels to Barbie dolls I
don't have an illustration for it but
perhaps you can visualize something if I
say you are Barbie to be clear film
movement is not a genre vampire films or
movies about Queen Victoria are genres
they are specific as to iconic content
what viewers will expect see as in fangs
or excuse me
her Judi Dench some genres are specific
to country samurai films from Japan
westerns from America sure filmmakers
other national origins try to make
samurai films not sell them in westerns
all too often nowadays the film movement
however is trans generic and time
delimited a period when different
filmmakers apply a common approach to
similar or diverse topics so here's a
vampire noir yeah there are some
westerns too there was a movement in
France called poetic realism Pepe lamoco
was one of them and I think you can tell
from the lighting it had a noir visual
style so sometimes people in a movement
they have a consciousness of what
they're doing I'm going to skip back now
for examples some images just say film
noir like this one from phantom lady in
1944 to film critics in 1946 in Paris
you know Franken Chartier coined the
terms
Chartier actually said Liz email account
won't see funny film Wow
and means Americans also make dark films
yeah dark not black because in that
context that's what noir means the thing
is genres wax and wane and popularity
and film noir however you defined it
hung around for a certain amount of time
producing movies by different filmmakers
with different actors different
screenwriters different producers
different directors at different studios
that were all film noir so there are a
lot to your samurai films in western
being made today but I'm sure we have
not seen the last two film Victoria
Queen Victoria movies
the thing about film noir is unlike
Queen Victoria it's no longer being made
it ended and full disclosure not
everyone agrees with me on that the
colleagues that I could write and edit
with believe film Noirs movement it
ended neo noir genre i confess i
confounded these things myself back when
I did the encyclopedia but I'm all in
now starting with the noir style in 1999
and continuing on everything I've done
since then there revisionist who claimed
the people who made film noir didn't
know what they were doing okay they
didn't have a word for it but they knew
what they were doing John Alton
Hungarian cinematographer this is work
that he did for three different
directors in a short period of years
that are all filmed warned what can I
say about doesn't matter I didn't have a
word for it sometimes I cite the
impressionist painters clearly had his
style they didn't have a word for it
until some critic we didn't like their
work called him impressionist they liked
the term and so they started using it
with regards another Alton movie the
biggan combo with regards to film noir
however one defines it it got made and
my usual best answer is to put up a
picture of director Robert Aldrich who
made the apocalyptic film noir Kiss Me
Deadly not big combo shot
by Alton and this is him standing on the
set of a war movie in 1956 holding a
copy of the first book about film noir
okay so for most people today
film noir means the same thing series of
movies made in the United States over
roughly two decades starting more or
less with the Maltese Falcon and ending
sort of with Touch of Evil in 58 more or
less because yes there are no our films
before and there some after but whenever
it starts or ends there's a classic
period of American film war during the
1940s and 50s comprised of three to four
hundred movies which Double Indemnity is
a defining example Maltese Falcon 1941
Bogart Mary Astor the lighting style
shadowed face on a not perfect looking
hero Bogart again looking weather-beaten
in a dark alley shadowed face broken
light behind him okay you can go full
face on Neff but the lighting is clearly
no art this is more this is noir and
this tradition continued Touch of Evil
the last the classic period Janet Leigh
and her stalker Orson Welles how can you
miss him
filling a doorway as only he could okay
so I'm not saying Double Indemnity is
defining because Frank and Sharky
mentioned it the reason they focused on
Double Indemnity aside from the fact
that they should we said it wasn't
available in France until 1946 when the
war had ended and suddenly movies could
get released they also liked Laura from
1944 first available to them in 46 and
they especially liked and again I don't
think I've explained to you why this is
film or this shot says it all murder my
suite based on a Chandler novel but
Chandler was not involved in it murder
my sweet Dick Powell
clear Trevor boy doesn't air here
like barbara stanwyck swig in
double-indemnity
no style carries over with more than
lighting so what makes Double Indemnity
defining well there weren't many new our
features produced and before Double
Indemnity they're only 20 features so it
was certainly in the vanguard of those
20 Paramount had made just for was it
defining because it has seven Academy
Award nominations including Best Picture
well yeah to some extent Maltese Falcon
got a Best Picture nomination eight
other noir films after Double Indemnity
did okay that's not a lot of movies out
of three to four hundred film noir never
became a mainstay of studio production
or never won a lot of awards but it
could be marketed there's a certain
marketing style in Hollywood art and it
features things like couples and guns
it's this little Caesar again pre noir
but setting a tone it's a dart was
enticing its stories might be tawdry but
they were exciting to the characters
they sang in sheet nightclub they
investigated lured crimes or committed
them they hid in dark alleys while black
sedans drove by tires hissing on wet
asphalt again a girl and a gun
frequently besides guns and passionate
embraces there was lots of money yeah
that is a film noir murder betrayal that
was the stuff the dreams were made of in
Maltese Falcon that was also the stuff
of Double Indemnity part of the reason
for that is however Double Indemnity
finally passed muster with Joe Breen not
a lot of noir storylines could and from
the first it stood out obviously it did
for those guys in France I've explained
why so let's talk about for health who
else it may have stood out this by the
way is Johnny eager in English in 1945 a
sunday supplement writer named Lloyd
Shearer he published a piece in The New
York Times Magazine
called crime certainly pays on the
screen sure didn't call him film noir
the term didn't exist here but he knew
what he was looking at just as much as
the filmmakers knew what they were
making and sure pointedly disapproved of
movies like Johnny eager or the
prohibited path I wake up screaming he
didn't think that was a good concept he
didn't approve of journey into fear and
he probably didn't approve of dark
waters he didn't like crime paying on
the screen what he said was the main
reason behind the current crop of
hard-boiled action-packed cinema murders
at the time-honored Hollywood production
formula follow-the-leader okay that's
one way to put it
one might also call it the start of a
film movement sure singles out the
paramount picture Double Indemnity
generally thought to be the first of the
new rough tough murder yarns how did
this movie come to be sure asks well
it's not often sure gets the credit he
deserves for the recognition he afforded
Double Indemnity in 1945 he made up some
stuff but what he mused about was did
paramount executives control one
another's say these times of death and
bloodshed and legalized murder these are
times when if an audience can stomach
newsreels of atrocities it can take
anything therefore that's by double
indemnity let's buy a cheap and make it
or did someone simply say this is a
fast-moving story let's do it sure
finally dramatizes the facts of how
Double Indemnity came to mate he tells
the story about one afternoon Joe
sistrum buzzed his secretary MS Velda
Victor and attractive brunette with blue
eyes no reply rang again still no answer
when he found her he says what's been
keeping you away from your desk for more
than an hour
according to Shearer miss Victor was all
aglow her eyes were Rhapsody's and glue
she couldn't contain herself her voice
shook like a taut rope this story it's
sensational
simply sensational it's James Kane it's
called double indemnity and it's a
natural for Billy Wilder to direct
you said while he was looking for a
story this is it it's hot it's sexy it's
exciting it's got everything even in
Germany they got it
well some of you were may read this
story before it's been in a bunch of
books I think it's even on Wikipedia but
I'm not sure if they got it completely
right
sure printed it first in 1945 so let's
consider yeah sure
there were killers before Double
Indemnity okay
there were Alan Ladd in this gun for
hire but that's a supporting role not to
lead there was Joseph Cotten he's a
smiling serial killer portray he kills
wealthy widows in Hitchcock's shadow
Vitt up but none of the ladies get
murdered on screen in 43 Double
Indemnity was published in book form
three of a kind
again Cain's agents sent it out this
time paramount bought the rights they
paid fifteen thousand the price in 1935
had been 25 so side note number one is
that side note number two as one might
expect from that money oriented writer
James Cain he went to his grave
believing Joe Greene owed him ten
thousand bucks
Joe Bremen long ago summed up his
assessment of general indemnity in a
memo that read the general low tone and
sorted player of the story makes it in
our judgment thoroughly unacceptable for
screen presentation before mixed
audiences or in the theater
long before the possibility of an art
rating the specific issues were bringing
for simple one the leading characters
are murderers and to the story deals
improperly with an illicit and
industrial and alterus sex relationship
what Joe Breen saw was an adulteress
clinch turns into a body on the tracks
and that just didn't work for the
production code administration now sure
colorfully suggest that maybe World War
two made it easier to stomach this but
what Breen wrote in 43 the absolute
caveat was the double indemnity could
not be a blueprint for murder conspiracy
to commit spousal murder for monetary
gains cannot be deemed
in place occurrence you know in terms of
film noir there are other movies about
this postman obviously also written by
Kane which came out in 46 but the
combination of adultery lust and murder
for money isn't all that common
yeah there's sexual obsession here's
Edward G Robinson at the feet of Joan
Bennett and his remake of a Renoir which
is called Scarlett Street Max Ophuls
caught was also about purported adultery
there are adulteresses apparently the S
couldn't fit but and Sheridan was an
adulteress in nor Prentice lady from
Shanghai with mr. wells again yes even
though she had his consent Rita
Hayworth's character was cheating on her
hubby pitfall Dick Powell is the guy
cheating but this shots more interesting
money sex murder they didn't really
coalesce again until the 40s with
criss-cross and here Dan Duryea getting
even for the adultery and for taking the
money at the end of that movie so it
really came down to a simple formula a
human desire or Fritz Lang movie if you
love me kill my husband but Glenn Ford
Gloria Grande
it's hottie behind him he decided not to
so the hubby kills the wife the concept
of human desire I mean it goes back to
Clytemnestra it's not all that
remarkable former it aside to be part of
more films but in many different ways
assorted trail of narratives keeps going
back to that defining moment in Double
Indemnity
now I'm gonna say part of the reason
roll the dice got rolled on Double
Indemnity not because the secretary
liked the yarn
yeah wildly wanted to do it and he was
just two features into his career and
decided he wanted a but
and because there were those seven
Academy Award nominations he got to move
from this movie and flirting with
pedophilia to a honey of an anklet
something that Joe Breen was never
comfortable with but he let it slide
there are other aspects that make Double
Indemnity defining that epitomized film
noir I mentioned how movement began
seated by analogs and that's kind of
what was going on with Double Indemnity
it was part of the seeding of what film
noir would continue to be for almost 20
years after this movie got made just
from the very opening set at night
that's changed from the a vocation of a
normal movie you've got the character
and you've got what he sees
they're both low-rent and it continued
the visual styles that got developed in
the early movies like Double Indemnity
crossed over I mean yeah it's in color
but this is the little sister Chandler's
eye section of the Hollywood that he
hated a few years later in a novel there
are many more aspects of Double
Indemnity that of define it as more but
really what keeps it more than anything
in that mode are the performances of its
character you know the gangster genre
introduced anti-heroes and film noir
took that concept and ran with it
this is 1955 Kiss Me Deadly the sneering
Private Eye Mike Hammer he comes from
Walter Neff and the disaffected look
when a woman is nuzzling his neck that
kind of comes from Walter Neff to the
whole dynamic of Double Indemnity
is replicated again and again in classic
film noir so it's not like Billy Wilder
was the only director that crossed upon
to make film noir brief list of European
Echo gaze
who crucial of the movement Kurtis
Bernard John brah Michael Curtiz Andre
de Toth William Dieterle Julianne TVPA
William Florrie William Dieterle I said
him
Boris Inkster Hitchcock Fritz Lang Ida
Lupino yes she was British rudolph met a
Lewis milestone John ago let's go max
ovals Otto Preminger Jean Renoir Robert
shod Mac Jack Turner Edgar G Ulmer Josef
von Sternberg Billy Wilder William Wyler
and Fred's intimate you've seen his
picture of wild liver Ford's from about
that era and besides directors you know
there's writers Leo Rosten chaud Mac
John Alton was Hungarian so was Ernest
Lazlo cinematographer so is miklós Rosa
the composer Daniel t'ought Roth was
European and lots of producers just
named - John Harris and Sam Spiegel what
is so significant about Double Indemnity
as film noir well you know besides
wilder and here's a picture of propria
to sense at Boulevard art director hands
dryer designer David Hall composer rocha
prop man jail called Conda makeup artist
Charles Gomorrah none of these people
were american-born but they all came to
participate in an American product I'm
going to spend a lot of time in the
script to screen process the you know
they got the rights
Brackett did not work on it whether he's
just giving wild her breathing room or
really hated Kane they found Chandler
they actually thought he was in New York
but they finally discovered he was six
blocks away they brought him in he
wasn't that they expected still they
hired him why not
so that wasn't a lovely relationship but
what the hell they worked it out they
wrote one of the finest screenplays in
the history of American motion pictures
and hated each other a lot of days yeah
Chandler wouldn't open a window you can
see Chandler was a happy man
and take a look at this one I'm sorry I
couldn't find a high-res okay he didn't
hate Chandler him put him in the movie
there he is I don't know if you saw him
and I I don't know nobody seems to know
why is there if Barbara Stanwyck wasn't
the first choice she was the
highest-paid woman in America in 1943
and she was under contract to Paramount
so why not use her there's a laundry
list of other actors I can leave this
after a while because it is by using
Barbara they also used reuse this wig
you know Alan Ladd gasps bless him five
foot six George Raft five foot seven
McMurray with six three by the way
that's the wig on Marlena Dietrich it
was originally used in manpower and why
it ended up on Phyllis's head I don't
really know okay they made the movie it
was pretty much a no-brainer
John sites under contract worked on five
graves with Wilder Rocha under contract
worked on five grades with Cairo and
finally there he is making a movie happy
to be doing it the the issue then became
you know will this movie turn out hey
yeah Chandler was a curmudgeon when he
his last job with strangers on a train
he wouldn't go to Warner Brothers he
made Hitchcock come to La Jolla and so
the master of suspense became the last
director to hate Chandler as human for
anything more movies after that here's
the thing about double indemnity it
exemplifies so much of film noir I've
usually written on at the point of view
of the perfect crime and I'm not like
saying it's the perfect movie but
honestly in terms of film noir in terms
of American cinema in the whole I kind
of side with Woody Allen's he ultimately
said it's brilliantly written a perfect
score it's Billy Wilder's best movie
practically anybody's best movie not
sure why Woody Allen fix that because
this is a movie about conspiracy and
betrayal love and sex murder and a
perfect crime that really isn't perfect
there linchpins avoir murder for profit
or not common conceits but I think what
really works in Double Indemnity besides
these pairings are the subtext of
relationships between the various people
the movie starts as you may recall with
Neff saying yeah I killed him I killed
him for money and for a woman I didn't
get the money and I didn't get the woman
pretty isn't it
well of course pretty it's not and
Double Indemnity is full of suspenseful
but unpretty moments would it have been
prettier uglier with the mitigating
factors that I've mentioned not in play
I don't know you know Breen Brackett
Chandler or Alan Ladd they were in they
were out obviously it made a difference
what if Joe's system is not read
Chandler's novel when they couldn't find
someone what if Chandler really lost his
temper at Wilder and stabbed him in the
back with a letter opener
it could have happened it didn't so
where does that leave us
it leaves us with a movie that really is
in many ways unparalleled you've got
John sizes 9 exterior photography you
have John sites whose remarkable
interior photography and it is so not
that it was so outlandish or so
experimental but it's rare you've got
these relationships you've got not just
Neff and Phyllis you've got Neff and
Lola you have phyllis and zachetti and
of course you got Neff and keys and
they're all part of this twisted concept
there are other monstrous women here is
a few may be better known Jane Greer is
Kathy Moffitt less well known but pretty
there she is about to shoot her husband
in the chest and throw his body in the
water
Elizabeth Scott has Barbara Palmer and
there's Stanwyck herself doing it again
in Strangelove Abarth Ivor's so this is
the key moment in the novel the thing
that sends Walter Hough
that's the novel's version reeling with
a chill down his spine this is the key
thing in the movie it's pretty clear
from when Neff says I wonder if you
wonder to this moment that he volunteers
and walks into this with his eyes open
you know there he is smiling at the
thought am I gonna kill someone for this
woman is she worth it and here's where
he ends up as he tells Keyes everything
gone right and takes a walk and decides
it was the walk of a dead man
the fatalistic tone of Double Indemnity
that's subtle sense of malaise it made
an impression on French critics but it's
sustained by its naturalistic and
hard-bitten performances just as much as
anything else
certainly that final embrace of Neth and
phyllis and the parlour it would not be
the same if it were not lit by thin
shafts of light that managed to pierce
the clothes venetian blinds it's also
the screen presence of these actors that
sell the moment the perfect crime having
eluded them Neff and Phyllis suffer the
fate predicted by his mentor Keyes yeah
they dine each other's arms or at least
she dies and he's wounded
you may know that there was actually
another ending but what was always there
was what Keyes said he says murder is
never perfect it always comes apart
sooner or later when two people are
involved it's usually sooner and it's
not like taking a trolley ride together
where they can get off at different
stops they're stuck with each other and
they've got a ride all the way to the
end of the line it's a one-way trip and
the last stop is the cemetery
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You mr. silver we now have time
for a few questions please raise your
hand and the microphone will be brought
to you
thank you very much for interesting talk
why did film noir capture the public
imagination at the time it did it had to
do with the world war it had to do with
something more more subtle than a
gangster genre the gangster genre made a
lot of money there were a lot of
gangster heroes but it wasn't until film
noir where you finally had heroes who
were not nice
but you could empathize with them yeah
you know I mean people empathize with
little Rico and little Caesar and
Scarface and certainly with Cagney is
Tom powers but they got killed you you
empathize for people I mean it was
anyone rooting for Walter to get away
with it because a certain part of the
audience a certain part of their feeling
about a lot of film noir anti-heroes was
you read for them for whatever reason
not reasons that Joe Breen liked but
reasons that are true in terms of
stories that go back to you know the
beginning of drama so it was the war it
was hard-boiled fiction finally being
dramatized they were very popular novels
not just Chandler's but Hammett's and
other people and it was those characters
being put on screen
Thanks
one thing that I've noticed in film noir
especially in Dublin demin ad was the
lighting and we're in some John Rose you
have romantic lighting you have high key
this was lighting where it came out of
the shadows and so much of all the
scenes was in the shadows and exceed it
seemed to be extremely difficult to be
able to shoot that and yet that was kind
of a de fight was that a defining style
of film noir and how many directors of
photography were actually able to shoot
in that style well if you look at the
late silent era in America there were a
lot of proto noir Josef von Sternberg
shot a couple that were out on location
used night photography it's not that
film stock was faster it's just simply
that it was easier to go out in the
field and throughout the 30s it was much
more difficult with sound equipment not
because the film stock wasn't fast
enough for the lenses weren't fast
enough now there were advances made in
World War two that made John Alton's
work a lot simpler
that's all location night photography
minimal amount of nights but with the
wherewithal of Paramount John Seitz shot
a lot of film noir and he's the common
factor and a lot of them in terms of his
approach which went back to the 30s
where he was constrained
yeah it's remarkable that they finally
managed to do it but it's just the
beginning and the technological advances
of the world war in terms of speed
lenses smaller lights more mobile camera
equipment let film noir explode in the
late 40s and 50s with that lighting
style like I said if you look at movies
and I've done it a couple of times you
can find seven features made in 1947
everything is different about them
producer/director studio actors
screenplay music but they're all film
noir and you just have to look at a few
frames to know that I noticed that when
Walter killed on the husband it was not
on screen you didn't see him actually
kill the husband and it struck me how
well number one how culture has changed
now where you don't you always expect to
see the the gruesome details if you will
was there was there some other reason
for that other than the culture has
changed or is it were there
considerations for the the ratings that
you mentioned or whether that was a
characteristic of noir films that they
didn't show the gruesome details we know
there's a couple of things obviously III
didn't go there's a lot of TTL that you
could look up about what wilder and
Chandler had to go through to make a
script it would be acceptable to Breen
it wasn't super hard but you know you
never saw that killing on screen it
wasn't in the script and if they wanted
to improvise it they conceivably would
have had a problem and then Paramount
would have had to cut it out knowing
that do something else I also think that
this sort of oblique approach what
happens is you stay on Barbara Stanwyck
and if you look at her expression as
it's happening
it starts from neutral and she subtly
smiles you can online you can find
people who have frame captured the
dissolve and how her expression changes
the I have a book coming out I didn't
write the piece in two months which has
double indemnity and the guy that wrote
that piece replicated three of those
frames and made that very point I think
it's very powerful is is not that they
couldn't do it they didn't want to and
it wasn't all breed it works
dramatically quite well I think the way
it is staying on Stanwyck letting the
actor carry that and carry the power of
the event in her face silent
no no words from her yes sir my mind
more of a comment that I was wondering
if you could expound on to me what's
interesting about this movie are our two
actors that are are basically the
they're on the trend thing of the term
but Fred MacMurray was an excellent
actor that Billy Wilder used here in the
1950s in the apartment and growing up
which dates me I think of might of him
there's a genial character my three sons
and and some of the Disney movies but
here you see a sinister side and then
Edward G Robinson who is a minor
character but he's the he's the
conscience he's the continuous thread
throughout all this and even being a
minor character the scenes he's in
you're riveted as as a movie goer you're
riveted on him he's such a fine actor
these were two people two actors to me
that we're really underestimated as far
as being true true talents that Billy
Wilder exploited I mean it's exploited
in a good way to showcase these two fine
actors you know that relationship
obviously it's a little bit in the novel
this crooking the house that's beating
his boss but the relationship as its
depicted in Double Indemnity it's
Chandler and Wilder going way past the
novel the first thing they did was throw
away a lot of scenes and some of that
was Wilders doing some of it with
Chandler Chandler is well known for
having said this dialogue works fine
when you read it but you're trying to
have actors do it it won't work
so they toss the dialogue and focused on
certain of the concepts a couple of the
concepts that they developed was number
one yeah the physical interaction the
father-son relationship it's not an inn
it's not an erotic relationship and yet
there's more to normal vos and more
mentor and protege but they did that to
all the relationships in tweaking them
slightly like you know phyllis and
zachetti were part of the novel so were
Neff and Lola but on screen with actors
it's very different from what you have
to force in a novel you can just put two
actors on screen I don't have to say
anything and it's there and I think to
Wilders credit more so than Chandler he
understood that and he understood what
he didn't need to do and how he could
create an interesting interaction just
by putting Robinson and Neff together in
the shot and letting them do these bits
of business was there more to it than
this father and son slightly oedipal
conflict know if it would explicit yet
some others said oh brain would have
said no you can't do that
so you know it kind of is what it is and
open to interpretation meant to be that
way yes
going on something of a tangent here
away from Wilder but staying I think
with in film noir one of my favorite
little films is a one called the set up
with Robert Ryan and Audrey totter are
you familiar with it well what part
Robert Ryan and Audrey totter it's
called the set up and to me it's film
doir but in it they kind of turned the
Convention on its head because the
betrayal was by his manager and you have
Audrey totter as the the woman who is
the opposite of femme fatale she stands
by Robert Ryan and is so would you
consider that film noir as well sure I
mean look film noir is a very broad
thing in terms of what it can
stylistically encompass especially in
terms of the classic period beginning an
end I'm curious about our norm of amp
our film I mean it's son of Dracula and
it's
long training but I showed you a frame
and it's by Robert Sean Mack who
directed you know the killers phantom
lady ten other Noirs he brought the
style to the vampire movie and what
Wilder I think understood and Chandler
to a certain extent was that it's not
about turning things on their head it's
about creating a powerful subtext just
using the actors not necessarily to
their words but through their
expressions I mean this is how really
good movies still get made today and
it's also about doing something
unexpected there are limitations and
most or some of them do some very
unexpected it's the whole concept of
standing things on its head that's much
later in war that's Kiss Me Deadly
that's Robert Aldrich anti bezerra T's
who wrote the script pointedly saying
everything explained did we're gonna
stand on its head it's rooted in Double
Indemnity it's rooted in all of the
early noir like I said this is about the
20th film noir made very early on in the
movement and so its influence continues
and what they did slightly other
filmmakers picked up on every aspect of
Double Indemnity has picked up on and
replicated here and there in many other
north
[Applause]